este será el primer discurso del estado
de la unión del presidente yo bailé
desde que llegó a la casa blanca y se da
en medio además de acercamientos a los
edificios principales en washington de
cara a estas manifestaciones que han
sido planeadas por transportistas en la
capital se enfocará en dos temas
principales en la economía y entre ellos
la inflación y también la guerra en
ucrania le va a pedir al congreso
específicamente que por favor apruebe
más ayuda militar a ucrania más armas y
más ayuda humanitaria de cara a esta
resistencia que está pues está poniendo
ucrania frente a la invasión rusa mira
textualmente en textos que fueron
filtrados por por la casa blanca que a
un dictador hay que hacerle pagar el
precio para que no genere más caos y que
entre otras cosas más avances por parte
de rusia genera más riesgos para eeuu
habrá una invitada especial para esta en
este discurso que empieza a las nueve de
la noche hora de washington será la
embajadora
ucrania en washington oksana makárova
ella estará al lado de la primera dama
de eeuu de baile y la intervención de
bailén llega en un momento en el que
tiene una baja popularidad y enfrenta
retos históricos como lo decíamos antes
cómo puede entonces beneficiarse de este
discurso de cara a las elecciones de
noviembre
si este es alarmante que desde noviembre
la popularidad de joe biden no ha pasado
por encima del 40 por ciento en este
momento según el washington post bis y
la popularidad de joe biden está en un
37 por ciento tiene un 55 por ciento de
desaprobación lo que mas desaprueban los
estadounidenses sobre el primer año del
presidente yo bailen en la casa blanca
es precisamente el la el manejo
económico y el manejo de la pandemia y
es que hay que resaltar que la inflación
está en el punto más alto en los últimos
40 años sin embargo pues el giro que
pretende darle el presidente joe biden
es el rol de líder mundial que ha jugado
en cuanto a ucrania y resaltar entre
otras cosas que eeuu es el mayor donante
de equipos militares y de armas a
ucrania con más de mil millones de
dólares atorados en el último año y
hablemos de este último punto que usted
menciona puede ayudarle a byd en
enfocarse más en las relaciones
exteriores durante su discurso
especialmente en medio de la guerra en
ucrania como usted lo decía y también
después de la salida de eeuu de
afganistán
exactamente lo que parece que está
tratando de hacer el presidente yo
vaivenes asumir un rol de liderazgo el
rol de liderazgo mundial que de alguna
manera le ayuda a escudarse detrás de
este rol de líder mundial de los
problemas que está enfrentando
localmente y es que muchos republicanos
en el congreso pues están haciendo mucha
oposición y están criticando mucho al
gobierno de la administración demócrata
de iovine del porque precisamente estos
paquetes de ayuda económica que superan
los mil millones de dólares mil puntos
de 1300 millones de dólares fue la lr el
paquete ayuda económica que está
tratando de pasar yo bailé en el
congreso pues según los republicanos
esto hará que haya mucho más gasto
público y precisamente este gasto
público para hacer que la economía
mejore pues simplemente termina
recalentando esta economía generando más
inflación sin embargo precisamente el
hecho de tener este este conflicto en
este momento y el riesgo que eso implica
para los mercados energéticos le ayudan
también al presidente yo bailé a
justificar la inflación precisamente por
los altos costos de la gasolina y el
petróleo que pueden terminar afectando
los de los estadounidenses un mensaje
claro que yo bailé me dará será a los
estadounidenses que se preparen para los
costos económicos que tendrán las
sanciones y el conflicto en ucrania